[Music]
Steve was like okay everybody
yeah I I am so excited to join you guys
everybody at Sophie bake and Jesse T
Usher and Kyle gone are with me who star
and smile which is in theaters Friday
how you guys doing good Steve we're
doing great
awesome I absolutely love this film and
so see this performance blew me away and
it seriously needs to be nominated for
awards what I want to ask you that's
nice
but why doesn't Hara get as much respect
with award shows
question I mean I don't know like like
um like
descendants or it's sort of feel like
anything that's like
big in in theaters and kind of like a
like uh you know I mean right now in our
culture
no movies that are in theaters actually
get considered um for like Awards I
think that like they have historically
sort of been ignored genre films you
know action movies horror movies
comedies like I think um it's just but
it's also part of the reason why I love
it because it's like you can't just do
sort of award movies and like be
accessible because not everybody like
wants to watch those whereas like you
know every like it's a real like thing
that brings people together from all
different walks of life so I don't know
I mean that's kind of why I like to do
it I want people to see go see movies
and I want everyone to and everyone to
have something to sort of
grasp onto yeah I think yeah and that's
that's a cool surprise of this film too
is that they get to see a big movie list
but they get an award-worthy performance
surprise so that's where we're going
we're moving that way now
Jesse this is probably the most
competitive Horror Season I can remember
with film why would you say smile over
the rest oh man
um wow based on the material smile was
one of the
only if not the only horror film while I
got to watch
a character that I felt like
I knew how they would handle a situation
and when they didn't handle the
situation the way that I expected them
to I understood it completely so Rose
has this area of expertise that I feel
like she would be able to tap into but
because of what she's going through I
completely understand why she's not able
to do it and that is um extremely
intriguing and Suzy bacon as you said is
absolutely incredible so seeing her play
that role
it doesn't matter what else is coming
out
no yeah and it's great and you all do
incredibleness and I love that you bring
up the story too and
Kyle I have to ask you too you are the
horror vet here do you love doing hard
deep down like better than any genre to
you or do you secretly like love
rom-coms do you want to do that I mean
look look we got a theme in this
interview here pairing other things
other things I've been comparing art to
Art is ridiculous I think sitting there
and putting like award shows I think
they're kind of ridiculous because I
think everything is made to be enjoyed
in its own way you know what I mean and
I think horror movies are definitely
their own monster definitely their own
Beast the fact that they're not as
appreciated and not considered as high
art or [ __ ] whatever as other stuff
is I think is crazy I mean it's
definitely its own style of filmmaking
you know what I mean you're gonna get
somebody who makes like The Godfather or
a movie like that and then tell them to
make a horror movie it's two totally
different skill sets right you know it's
two totally different animals so I
really enjoy I really enjoy the hard
genre because I think
you can tell
the
storytelling in horror movies like it's
it's just such a different thing you can
go to so many different places because
you're already being asked to believe
the unbelievable right so there's kind
of like no rules and I think that's a
lot of fun and I think just that style
of Storytelling should be more
appreciated and where we're at now the
way people are telling those stories you
are having these knock down drag out
performances like so see gives you know
what I mean that
they need to start putting some respect
on Horror's name I think like a little
bit more for sure if we are going to
compete art against Art I think horror
movie should definitely be put up there
into that category and I think it's
coming it's nope nope is getting
considered for Awards this year isn't it
that's kind of a big thing yeah I didn't
know if it was but I I don't know I'm
not that thing get out did yeah like I
think we are like kind of things are
coming you know it's it's starting to
happen which I think is very cool
yes yeah no I that's a great answer it's
totally true hard deserves more respect
and I think this film's just going to
serve that purpose totally guys thank
you so much for joining me today and
everybody watch these three crush it and
smile and theaters Friday Friday baby
thank you